o concept banda beijo certo modo serve o
escritor que chegou a ocupar o cargo de
chanceler do reino das oitavas a
inglaterra é geralmente considerado como
um dos grandes humanistas do regimento
das figuras históricas que diziam e
lutavam público pensar no que vai dar
vez que vem de longe
acho que há um ano
então a proposta de gente diz o pensa
tomás moro você foi o homem que está por
matar chtou off político advogado
jurista nessa sua outra atividade você
diz sempre pensa que seus de acrescentar
que eu era um humanista e profundamente
cristão é muito bem e de sábado por
termos políticos muito
bastava olhar para o mundo foi a
impunidade e injustiça ea certeza de que
não se podia formar ou melhorar esse
sistema de organização social que mundo
vou imaginar uma ideia louca incensada
pretendem tentar abrir os olhos das
pessoas hoje o youtube
sonhei com um renovado e em frente ao
meu caro amigo e vou chamar alguém que
gostaria de ouvir
fui fundador do nazismo moto na cidade
cruel em seis grupos que organizou o
extermínio de milhões de judeus em
campos de concentração do setor no
socorro a otan está ligando união
soviética e pensa se terá suicidado no
seu bumbum
quando o exército vermelho se não parar
um pouco para a capital desse pele gorro
e do crime
o brasil espera esteja autocrítica
a amm e você promoveu uma unidade de um
paciente é pai e nos carros
eu só peguei a última batalha mas ganhei
muitas outras
retiramos os pactos da marinha de guerra
civil de espanha de meio milhar de
funcionários em todo o mundo
olho por olho e qualquer o mundo acabará
sei lá o senhor não quer perceber o
avanço do mundo povos e continentes se
libertar do clube mesmo nos anos 60 via
também não seja elenco
nos anos 60 se ganhar alguma coisa
fomos nós a amarra os assassinos dos
irmãos campana x hamilton embarca lomba
humberto delgado
amílcar cabral mais um milhão de mortos
na alemanha o canadá sua vez que obama
fez nessa opção com os inimigos kogan
vocês nunca se divertiu claro no livro
lembra isso ajudava muito bem os objetos
do nosso fazer segredo
os móveis que todo eleitor não deve ter
um grande território é que nós
julgávamos dessas histórias é gostar de
vocês está enganado
o nazismo eo fascismo que era uma grande
demanda na europa a noite ruim era
famosa é e urbanismo drogas sexo
corrupção tudo em nome da lei rodada
contra a russa vermelha festas bailes
funk e festas música muita música
a proposta é chamar outro convidado já
não foi um músico e da lista
cantor compositor escritor britânico
união como um dos fundadores do grupo
rock britânico the beats
muito obrigado normal
então não é no 1 mil do livro booky
conquistou o mundo e os batons mais
algumas pessoas só acho que essa foi uma
fase de grande preocupação
infelizmente é verdade foi um dos vários
desafios que fizemos o consumismo ea
guerra do vietnã um bonzinho angeles nos
estados unidos
patrícia outro dia é utopia achar que o
saiba você foi um grande tópico iria
durar milano a luta ainda não terminou
porque é preciso convencê los da sua
importância é temos que convencer que
ouvimos com atenção e com respeito a
nosso ver os intelectuais que tomam ser
a jóia da coroa dos prudentes a porta
por alguns dessas falhas no partido mas
é de 80 prá cá nada basta a administrar
e obviamente as bolsas às tensas jóia e
depois comentar a concorrência entre os
aqui tratando a campanha é de descrédito
quanto o do outro
vamos acompanhar o processo e mesmo que
os outros
hambúrgueres em chaves há sempre
intelectuais que não estão consigo
nesses casos você só pode matar e
destruir seu mais belo espetáculo do
mundo
o mar está um pouco afinal o que a idéia
do governo seria um novo estado uma
república e enviá lo em que é
propriedade privada ea moeda seria uma
bolina se esse é o centro do ida estava
eu sempre acompanhava privada
sim a ideia tem de ser lida com um como
um sonho pelo qual talvez valha a pena
lutar por exemplo que todos trabalhem
para que todos possam trabalhar - que
todos sejam tratados do mesmo modo
homens e mulheres e crianças que ninguém
passa na cidade que ninguém seja
considerado superior aos outros por ter
mais coisas do que anos digamos digamos
que são projeto não prevê ao conhecem
como eduardo galeano fala do outro e
está lá no horizonte próximo dois passos
os dois passos eu caminho dez passos e
horizonte com dez passos
por mais que o caminho jamais alcançará
outro dia um preço que não dá estreando
como o projeto era correto e armado povo
em 1980 as novas os magnatas da bolsa a
nosso favor como a favor do vulcão
porque a luta da classe c é estranho o
mais natural seria haver uma revolução é
também é verdade que nas situações de
crise
o povo só explica por um de um salvador
nós só precisamos convencer o que não é
de todo o terreno que nós é que somos o
salvador ainda ver voltas peço desculpa
nesse caso a exercemos a violência ea
vingança
ao rejeitar tratarem do seu o do raul
chega se isso a utilização da tecnologia
o recenseamento é nós cultivamos a é
demagogia
nós utilizamos a técnica de matar
negociar é voltar a mandar voltar a
negociar e até nuclear completo e mail
e nessa sutil não houve ódios invejas
miséria a sociedade justa
baseia se no trabalho e nas relações
humanas conjunto pianos além de
agricultores aprendendo determinados
ofícios também são opções dreyfus
oleiros 30 eles as mulheres que
trabalham nos serviços mais leves como a
personagem em trabalhar muito
seis horas três manhã almoço duas horas
esta empresa à tarde
saia camasmie às oito da noite dormem
oito horas
não falta nada podem podem estudar mesmo
antes do terceiro do sol já é há cursos
a funcionar em sítios para falar para o
caro para ouvir música
não não é tabernas não a sugerir por 10
nem sítios para encontros secretos no
corpo três se chamou dia bem difícil
construir não era o que dizia o meu
amigo erasmo elogio da loucura loucura
sonhos gouveia em oitavo
o nomeou como chanceleres para eu
conseguir um divórcio ea anulação do seu
casamento com catarina de aragão o papa
clemente sétimo era claramente contra a
demora se eu era católico
por isso demiti me demitido do cargo da
lord chance é é pecado pecado copiado
não isp órgão que isso r coitado abril
cesce si mesmo
atribuir se mesmo a liderança da igreja
da inglaterra sendo o sacerdócio
obrigado a um juramento que o consagrava
um chefe supremo da igreja que você foi
convocado para fazer o juramento franco
saí fui preso na torre de londres
no entanto lugano se de não dizer razões
pelas quais não 3 teria o juramento
julgado e condenado à morte que querem a
qualquer momento se a voz e fazer o
jeito do taco de bócio que eu queria
o vaticano todo dia aceitava algum
negócio acaba tudo bem agora agora 68
pia que a minha morte
a sentença eu era condenado a ser
suspensos pelo pescoço a cair em terra
ainda vivo depois ser esquartejado e
decapitado em atenção a importância do
condenado murray por clemência produziu
a pena a simples de captação é em birmal
high tech é ingratidão enquanto o
contrário eu só isso não permite a deus
que o rei tem é semelhante pelo menos e
com os meus amigos mas negando essa
relação corpo dele é sempre muito
difícil
na altura quando eu nem os bebedouros
envolve a medalha de membro do império
britânico a rainha elizabeth como forma
de protesto contra o apoio do reino
unido à guerra do vietnã é pretender que
você quiser santeiro mais utilizado o
twitter
isso porque a energia por toda a parte e
eu era um pacifista combatendo a nota da
ram algoz dos outros né
odon por baixo lutando pela paz acusando
a vergonha de fazer o mal não ser feliz
com a influência do soul
é vergonha vergonha os nazis ganhar vão
voltar a ganhar a partir da mente porque
não tenho sentimento bo rede questão da
amazônia estão prontos para tudo outra
vez pra todos os ouros já quer saber
coisas sobre os campos de concentração a
solução final é para judeus a técnica
não é você continua mesmo continua mesmo
diário judeus
eu só tenho abril do ano corrente pi
agora já quando se termina piores
baratas ratos partido para defender a
saúde então ato contra organismos ligo
que não potencia o jardim romano um
judeu tá nessa categoria mas isso sou
afirmações monstruosos hora do jogo eu
gostaria mesmo é que é também porque
você enxerga aí vieram para trabalhar
testou renan estava causa da copa
servirão para os clientes do domingão
hoje nós queremos servir um prato de
papel para fazer esta pato sapatilha
para fazer maya
urge vossos servirão para a prainha
protocolo a volta gordura trans foram 31
é os votos dentro do ouro os fios
serviram para fazer um negócio do ouro
do banco haxixe
é enfim um país
o fogo é isso tudo
alimentada por uma lei mal e andré
você não está jogando nada programado
tudo isso é preto no filme o judeu e não
havia banho nunca conseguiram superar
deus
caso o partido é iluminado por um tinha
o chefe é um deus concreto num modelo de
inventar um poderoso da ordem que
discuta o domingo ainda parte dos nazis
com força total
é eu não existem patrões que ele é não
só necessário é pouco nosso militante
está nos partidos do poder
os negócios estão nos jornais em um
trecho foi por isso muitos milhares de
jovens região se preparam para a luta
que você está falando muito juntos
sim eu tinha na altura grande na
política criticava presidente richard
nixon era conhecido tinha aquele que
fazia canções racistas antigo x tg
contra a brutalidade policial era
considerado perigoso principalmente com
o texto da imagem
vou dar uma alegria ao usando a sua
abrangência
todos se diz noiva do carlense
influência mas fiquei triste por ter
sido assassinado
aos 40 anos acho que ainda tinha muito
trabalho para fazer
onde tiver que é penico que não
acontecia nada
a dimensão trágica da sua boxe ficou
mundo ainda precisa decidir carta disse
que era doloroso que você tivesse dessa
ciranda imposto é realizada a campanha
pela paz durante tanto tempo
parece que parece um carro aqui é o amor
negro britânico o seu assassino então
chefe mano
esse motivo do crime é o show depois
fêmeas isso e não acreditar em cristo
os estados unidos continuam com essa
força fanática religiosa era o clube só
agora ti para áfrica e médio oriente
sofrem com a diminuição das guerras
entre elas o barco fundamento
o slot um novo mais um agora de barba e
turbante o nosso resto foi rápido e
pouco rentável
eu dizia que a humanidade não tem mesmo
concerto não tem conserto
demos lhe então outro concerto a médium
não é
o campo